on this friday night
the prime minister's warning to contain
canada's deadly surge
we need to step up now provinces
toughen up and expand restrictions as
infection rates explode
we have to get the community spread
under control a widow's pain
after the verdict in new brunswick's
mass shooting we
don't ever get the opportunity to pack
up our grief and put it away
why did a jury find the accused killer
not criminally responsible
not all are on board why many in an
ontario town
are turning their backs on a concept to
transport goods
on trains over tracks
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
robin gill good evening and thank you
for joining us
we begin with a difficult but urgent
message to canadians about the spread of
kova 19.
with case numbers surging prime minister
justin trudeau is warning
if we don't do more now to limit our
contacts with other people
canada is on a path to disaster the only
way we can reverse the tide
is if we immediately reduce
the number of people each of us come
into contact with
if you live in a region that is
experiencing a surge in cases
stay home if you can and avoid all
non-essential travel we need to step
up now all of us
here's what could happen if we don't
make changes according to new federal
modeling
if we keep doing what we're doing canada
could hit 20 000 cases a day
by the end of the year if we increase
our social interactions
that number could skyrocket to 60 000
cases a day
if we reduce our contacts to essential
activities only
canada can get the second wave under
control
global's david aiken has more on the
prime minister's message and what's at
stake
as canada heads into winter i don't want
to be here this morning
you don't want me to be here this
morning but here we are again the cases
across the country
are spiking massively the prime minister
back in front of his home to make the
point that canadians should stay home
when they can and
take other measures to crush the 19
curve
i am today using my voice
and my position as prime minister to
talk to all canadians
to tell them that we're in a serious
situation where they need to listen
to their premiers they need to listen to
their public health experts on
what they can do in their jurisdictions
to do more
the reason a grim forecast on the eve of
winter
continuing on the current course means
twenty thousand new cases a day by year
end
versus the current rate of five thousand
new cases a day
but absolutely do not go above what we
are have
now otherwise um you know we are in
um really in trouble already critical
care beds are at or near capacity in
some parts of the country
and the disease is now picking up in
indigenous communities and in nunavut
where health resources are scarce and
options to isolate are few
and yet trudeau said the tough decisions
about more lockdowns and
more restrictions must be left to the
provinces
not ottawa provinces have lots of tools
at their disposal
and i'm not looking to bring in a
federal
federal hammer still critics say that
has led to confused and mixed messaging
masks are mandatory in one region but
not another
gatherings allowed here but not there
it's unfair and it's frustrating yep
there's no question about it but we're
not in a fair situation
and it will be like this for weeks a
normal christmas
is quite frankly right out of the
question the goal now
keep as many canadians as safe and
healthy as possible
until the first vaccines arrive david
aiken global news
ottawa here's a look at the situation in
canada today in terms of new infections
there were 17 new cases reported in the
atlantic bubble and
10 new cases in nunavut bc has 516 new
cases
alberta broke another record with 1155
cases
across the prairies infections remain
oringly high there were more than 1200
new cases
in quebec and 1400 in ontario
tough new restrictions are coming into
force in parts of ontario
toronto and peel region two of the
hardest hit
are headed back into lockdown my friends
i've been clear on this the situation is
extremely serious
and further action is required to avoid
the worst case scenario
schools will remain open but starting
monday most
non-essential businesses will close
there will be no indoor dining and
people cannot socialize indoors with
anyone outside their household mike
chile has more on the new restrictions
and the reaction for the past week
premier doug
ford has warned ontarians they were
staring down the barrel of another
lockdown
today on his birthday he pulled the
trigger
effective monday november 23 at 1201 am
tron on peel will be moved into lockdown
the rules are strict no indoor private
gatherings and
religious ceremonies will have limits of
10 people non-essential retail and
restaurants will be open
for pickup and delivery only but gyms
casinos and theaters
will all be closed which is devastating
news for the business community
the business is already in an incredibly
weakened position
how many more days those businesses can
stay alive
is is anyone's guess but we're
predicting an
absolute bloodbath in the days ahead uh
with one in seven small firms
permanently closing their doors
forever uh gosh i'm deeply worried
and any additional business restriction
is going to hurt hard
manufacturing and construction will stay
open as will schools
but ford says there was no longer any
room for half measures
ford's announcement came just a few
hours after the toronto raptors
delivered their own bad news
with the federal government blocking all
attempts to play in canada
the decision was made for the team to
relocate to tampa
for the upcoming season there was just
no way of ignoring the surging wave of
covet 19 cases
i'm really hoping in this crisis at this
point
that people are actually listening over
the past two weeks ontario's seven day
average for new cases
has risen 29 percent but in that same
period of time the number of
hospitalizations has increased 36
percent
and most concerning covet cases in icus
have risen 65 percent
which is nearing the threshold for what
the health care system can handle
without emergency measures frankly it
didn't need to come to this if
doug ford had not dithered if he had not
introduced a series of half measures
throughout the fall
and had been decisive earlier in this
pandemic
we we would not be i don't think in the
shape that we're in right now
if the numbers go down the hope is the
holidays won't be a total loss
but for now they're looking awfully
quiet mike relay global news toronto
a man in his 20's has become the
youngest person in manitoba to die of
cover 19.
he was among the nine people reported
dead today in total now in manitoba
more than 200 people have died of the
virus
all these announcements are much more
than numbers
these are these are people this is a
young man
there's certainly some underlying
conditions but
this is uh you know tragic to see
all of these listings every single day
dr rusin also warned about an escalating
crisis southeast of winnipeg
in the city of steinbach 40 of all
people getting tested
are receiving positive results russon is
calling for immediate action to help
bring case numbers
down in this second wave the number of
outbreaks in long-term care homes across
the country continues to rise
today 102 homes in ontario are in
outbreak mode
with eight new deaths reported families
are fed up calling for
action abigail beeman checks in on the
state of things
in long-term care across the country
vascular dementia and alzheimer's
but she's still with it enough to know
that i'm not there with her
roseanne riley's mother is 104.
23 people have died at her ottawa
long-term care home
riley says her mom was left with a
coveted positive roommate for 48 hours
saturday she tested positive the
protocols are in place
and we're doing what we should be doing
i mean
how does this happen riley was one of
several people who shared concerns about
the ontario system friday shut these
houses
of horror down she died alone
my priority now is the well-being of my
father
within the long-term care system the
grieving spouse
we have to lock this down no excuses
anymore
this week ontario announced increased
long-term care testing and 3 000 new
beds
we are investing more than half a
billion dollars in additional supports
for long-term care
during the second wave we're seeing
these homes in ontario
which has the most outbreaks and other
places like manitoba
that never actually had staffing
contingencies in place
really see the brunt of a lack of
preparation experts say nationwide the
second wave is just as troubling
staffing shortages are still an issue
plus there's an
increase in community transmission in
the second wave rather than the military
now we're starting to see the red cross
half the residents of this winnipeg care
home have coveted 19
so short staffed they're asking family
members to come monitor loved ones
quite a reduction in staffing because of
kovid transmission the ers
team the paramedics are there right now
while saskatchewan announced a new
visitor ban at care homes
except on compassionate grounds and nova
scotia is now stopping residents from
leaving for off-site visits
but the province's top doctor says
visits at the home
must continue you need to look after the
care of the residents
not just their physical health but their
mental health as well
it's not okay to put barriers to that
happening
as for this 104 year old extendicare
tells global news they can't speak to
her
case due to privacy but that separating
positive residents is a priority
riley wants more answers i know she's
old
but she's my mother and she means
something to me
abigail beeman global news ottawa
a vaccine is key to fighting covid 19
and getting our lives back to normal
today drug maker fis are applied for
emergency vaccine approval
in the u.s the filing starts the process
that could bring a limited number of
shots as early as next month
the u.s food and drug administration and
its independent advisors will now debate
if the shots
are ready earlier this week pfizer
announced its vaccine appears to be 95
percent effective
competitor moderna also expects to seek
emergency authorization
of its vaccine in the history of
coronaviruses why does covid19 cause
such
swift and widespread illness new
research suggests patients diagnosed
with cova-19
are especially infectious in the first
few days of the illness
as eric sorensen tells us the report
reinforces the need to isolate as soon
as symptoms appear
with many viruses people often get the
first cough or sniffles and just carry
on going to work or meeting with others
but with covet 19 health officials
emphasize the need to isolate quickly
and a new study explains why research in
the lancet microbe compared
coronaviruses from previous outbreaks
and finds that symptomatic patients
diagnosed with covet 19
had the highest levels of live virus in
the first few days
this virus more so than a couple other
viruses seems in some patients to shed a
lot of virus so
when you're sick you're actually
releasing a lot of virus and that's
always problematic for infection of
other people
the covert 19 virus was most infectious
very early in the first five days after
the onset of symptoms with previous
outbreaks
years ago with sars and mers the viral
load peaked later
with mers seven to ten days after the
onset of symptoms
and with sars 10 to 14 days later so
with those viruses the symptoms would
tip you off early
and you could isolate before the
infection was at its worst
but with covet 19 the infectiousness is
at its worst as soon as the symptoms
appear
which is why covert 19 is so hard to
contain
other studies have shown some covid
carriers are infectious before they show
symptoms making the spread even harder
to contain
and that's why we ask people when
they've potentially had contact
to self-isolate regardless of whether
they're currently testing positive or
not because we're still missing
that critical piece of information
before you develop symptoms
while the virus spreads quickly the
lancet research also found that no
live virus remained in symptomatic
patients after nine days
so the infectiousness to others does
drop off dramatically
one other new study says covet carriers
develop immunity that is now shown to
last at least
six months this is potentially
significant news it extends the period
for which we know there is likely
protection
evidence of a strong immune response
gives researchers optimism
that vaccines now in development will
also have lasting immunity
eric sorensen global news toronto
the verdict many victims families didn't
want coming up a jury finds the
fredericton shooter
not criminally responsible
two years ago fredericton was rocked by
a mass shooting
matthew raymond shot and killed four
people including two police officers
today a jury found him not criminally
responsible because of a mental disorder
for more on the verdict and how the
community is reacting
let's go to global's silas brown silas
it took the 11-member jury 25 hours over
the course of four days to reach a
verdict
after the verdict was read raymond could
be seen wiping tears from his eyes
and some members of the victim's
families ran from the room
and could be heard sobbing in the
hallway jackie mclean is the widow
of rob costello one of the police
officers killed
i was hopeful that he would be found
responsible for it
only because
i don't think he's acknowledged
responsibility or his
his responsibility for this here's how
the case has unfolded
raymond faced four counts of
first-degree murder dating back to the
morning of august 10
2018 when he opened fire from inside his
fredericton apartment
the shooting began just after seven in
the morning and lasted less than half an
hour
donald robichaud and bobby lee wright
were shot as they packed up their car
for a camping trip
fredericton police constables sarah
burns and rob costello were the first
officers on scene
responding to the active shooter call
and were shot before they could draw
their weapons
that raymond shot and killed the four
victims was never in dispute
his lawyers admitted as much but they
argued that raymond should be found not
criminally responsible for his actions
due to a mental disorder and three
separate forensic psychiatrists have
diagnosed raymond with either
schizophrenia
or delusional disorder during the trial
but the central issue the jury was
tasked with deciding
is if that mental disorder impaired
raymond's ability to understand the
nature
and quality of his actions or that they
were wrong raymond testified that he
believed the end times had begun
and that he was under attack by demons
having barricaded himself inside his
apartment
with loaded weapons for days the defense
has argued that this is supported by the
mountain of electronic data
the crown has acknowledged that raymond
was experiencing delusions the day of
the shooting
but says that they were less intense
than he claims and that he targeted the
four victims knowingly
raymond will now be sent to new
brunswick's psychiatric hospital
in campbellton where he will await a
disposition hearing in december
that will decide if he is treated at the
federal or provincial facility
robin silas brown in fredericton new
brunswick tonight
still ahead donald trump's new strategy
to ignore american democracy
the cases of kofi 19 in the united
states are soaring to new levels
more than 80 000 people have been
hospitalized that's the most since the
pandemic
began the u.s has also set a new daily
covid19 record
more than 187 000 people tested positive
yesterday the u.s president is showing
unprecedented disregard for democracy
today donald trump met with state
lawmakers from michigan in a bid to
convince them to ignore the will of
voters
let's bring in our washington bureau
chief jackson proskow jackson what is
trump's strategy here
well robin simply put trump wants
republican-controlled state legislatures
in key swing states to ignore the fact
that voters picked joe biden and instead
appoint a new slate of electors to the
electoral college
remember it's those electors who
ultimately go on to pick the president
those two michigan lawmakers you
mentioned flew to washington today to
meet with president trump
it's not clear what they discussed but
it is clear that this is part of a
maximum pressure campaign
to get several states to ignore the
wishes of voters
shortly before that meeting we should
point out that trump again insisted he
won the election
robin it's very clear he did not but he
continues to argue that there was some
kind of voter fraud
is there proof
no there is no proof at this point and
not only has he not
offered proof of the 30 lawsuits filed
by the trump campaign
only one has been successful most of
those complaints have fallen apart or
simply been withdrawn due to a sheer
lack of evidence
tonight the state of georgia though is
moving ahead with certifying its results
in favor of joe biden
they found no fraud or irregularities
that would stop that from happening
meanwhile biden's team seems to be
losing patience with the stalled
transition
the president-elect today met with
democratic congressional leaders like
nancy pelosi
they together have not ruled out going
to the courts to compel
trump to cooperate with the transition
process a courtesy we should point out
that was extended to trump by outgoing
president barack obama four years ago
jackson prescott washington thanks
jackson
up next could a train project in ontario
derail the health of people
living nearby
one effective way to reduce greenhouse
gas emissions is transporting goods
across the country by train
instead of truck cn has been pushing to
do that for 20 years
it wants to build a terminal where
shipping containers can be transferred
onto trains
but some residents in milton ontario the
proposed site
aren't on board jeff semple explains
priscilla burton's five-year-old son
suffers from asthma
and their home town of milton an hour's
drive west of toronto
offers a breath of fresh air we had more
access to like
countryside and farms and conservation
areas
but burton's family like many others
here is worried
about a new neighbor poised to move in
down the street
cn the canadian national railway
purchased this stretch of land
with plans to build an intermodal
terminal
the facilities provide an environmental
benefit by taking long-haul trucks
off the road and transferring goods onto
trains
it's a great idea i fully support it
there's just one problem with milton
it's the wrong place this transportation
analyst
says most terminals like this one in
nearby brampton are
built in industrial areas but in milton
it's a much different story
cn's proposed site here in milton sits
just across the street from a sprawling
residential area within a kilometer of
thousands of residents
a hospital and a dozen schools
the site would see 800 transport trucks
rolling in and out of the area every day
an independent government review panel
found most of the adverse environmental
effects from the terminal are
likely to occur anyway because the lands
have been designated for future
development
but the panel concluded the terminal is
likely to cause significant adverse
environmental effects on air quality
and on human health as it relates to air
quality i'm not just talking about one
or two and i'm talking about the masses
of the people just don't want it but in
this case the community
doesn't get to decide the rules
governing rail companies
are as old as canada written back in
1867 the constitution ensured railways
were the domain of the federal
government
as a result cn's fate falls to the feds
this could be saskatoon this could be
vancouver
it could be halifax it can be anywhere
cnn declined our request for an
interview but noted the review panel
also found
cn's criteria for site selection were
reasonable and the proposed site could
support an intermodal terminal
they're kind of putting their company's
interest ahead of our health the
government's decision is expected within
a month
jeff semple global news milton ontario
and tomorrow an environmental health
expert who studies cancer risks weighs
in with his take on the risk posed by
pollution from the proposed terminal
that's on our program the new reality
saturday at 7 pm with donna friesen
right here on global and that is global
national for this friday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada
is cashabog lake in ontario thank you
for watching and i'll see you here this
weekend have a great night